dans l'actualité sociale ce matin des
grévistes ont bloqué la raffinerie total
de grandpuits pour protester contre la
suppression d'emplois est les salariés
sont en grève depuis le 4 janvier contre
un plan de restructuration qui prévoit
des suppressions d'emplois sur le site
de seine et marne selon les syndicats
700 postes sont menacés et depuis ce
matin ils ont mis en place un barrage
filtrant pour bloquer l'accès à la
raffinerie les grévistes envisagent
d'autres actions coup de poing dans les
prochains jours alors l'objectif ce
matin c'est d'augmenter un petit peu le
rapport de force puisqu'on est en
conflit est en grève reconductible
depuis le 4 janvier
donc l'objectif de ce matin c'était de
désorganiser complètement l'entreprise
et les gens qui vient d'intervenir
pour faire des travaux voilà et puis
aussi de désorganiser
dans la distribution de carburant
puisque on fait aussi de la filtration
au niveau des canons qui viennent
s'alimenter en produits en produit
fiscal ou prou tarde pas trop parce que
lula au brésil donc voila mais après oui
les jours de la raffinerie je comprends
un peu parce que là les choses qui vont
mal de la race hybride entre bon bah ils
ont besoin de se défendre
donc oui je pense que c'est c'est ce qui
ce qu'ils font c'est vous et j'ai fait
la même chose si j'ai besoin et j'ai
combien s'élève à chacun essaye de
sauver son métier aux bulls tout paraît
temps qui courent
alors quoi